the next get a little break from the
ballroom floor rehearsal come see a
movie I mean kind of took today off
great I forced her to take today I was
like that said I called her a gel-like
you cancel every year after their first
perfect score of the season
laurie hernandez and her pro partner Val
Chmerkovskiy enjoyed a well-earned break
from dancing Thursday night still
running on that high from that moment uh
yeah I mean I still can't believe it
it's amazing because we train so hard
for and we only had three days to
prepare for it and I'm just really happy
it worked out the perfect pair hit up
the LA premiere of middle school the
worst years of my life what's three
words to describe your middle school
experience here's three I didn't go I've
been homeschooled I'm kind of curious to
see what it's actually like I guess you
dodged a bullet
tell us man three words braces pimples
and just an awkward swag that I thought
was cool at the time so you're just
basically delusional throughout an
entire middle school days